[Music]
I gotta ask you really quick about
Ghostbusters three they're doing another
one Leslie Jones had kind of an adverse
reaction to it I was wondering what your
thoughts were because I want to see the
ladies come back I want it to be a
crossover universe uh you know what I'm
for anybody who's making movies I think
you know Jay I talked to Jason about it
he's like he just always had this idea
and his goes back to like the world
where the guys didn't exist and I'm like
I want to see that I'm all for it I say
like tell the story I think there's a
million stories to be told he's a really
really good filmmaker and a really good
storyteller so I will be there buying my
ticket I'm all for it Glenn Close
tonight can you talk about your
relationship with Glenn
she's just something's got to be wrong
with her I don't know what it is yet I'm
really digging because she's just too
cool like you just it's everything you
wanted to be times a million and doesn't
take yourself seriously and when you
look at the war that she's done and how
she just kind of differs the work and at
the same time kind of let yourself be
taken away by it I mean it's just no
matter how many great people they're
like everyone can't do that and then
should be such a good person and
humanitarian on top of it and like a mom
and she just really is she's cool to be
around it's like it makes you raise your
game and I think it's a good thing to
watch kind of powerful women like that
operate in such a lovely way
[Applause]
[Music]